gibt ein paar pluspunkte nicht damit bei
25 punkten war der erste für das heißt
in einem monat wie so zeige ich dann
jetzt mal in einem monat kommen eine
neue kollektion raus in den kampf
die klang nicht so überzeugt ich habe
mir gedacht dass wir in einem monat
meiner neuen klamotten in den shop
kommen werden ich heute mal auf ein
video reagiere wo dieses mädchen auf
meine klamotten reagiert und die
bewertet von crafter freundin von
crafter luca freundin luca und jule
warum
benutzt du das als text bewertest meine
klamotten der mitmenschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abgestoßen ich werde euch
übrigens am ende des videos noch ein
neues produkt vorstellen was am ersten
sechs in den shop komplett ich habe eins
habe ich ja an dienstag habe ich euch
auch schon gezeigt den rudi habe ich
euch schon gezeigt allerdings jetzt
reagieren wir erst mal 1000 mann lieben
und willkommen zu einem neuen werbung
was realität heute mit word von
geringeren als kong kraft den kenn ich
wer finde ich bisher sehr gut gemacht
das video also sie steht ihr vor seiner
gelben wand beziehungsweise einem
greenscreen ich weiß es nicht ganz genau
schöner blick hier gerade übrigens ist
sehr cool gestritten aber wir schauen
mal weiter auf japan sich geändert die
blicke sind gleich aber ich finde dieses
ziel nach wie vor sehr cool
danke ich dachte echt zudem selbst
komplett auseinander so auf jeglicher
basis auch hier in jeglicher hinsicht
irgendwie aber cool
danke dass es dir gefällt als wenn man
bei mir im shop ist sie deshalb bei
jedem bild so aus als wenn ich die ganze
zeit so ernst gleich gucken und hab halt
nur verschiedene sachen dann aber wenn
man mit der maus darüber fährt dann mach
ich halt immer verschiedene die masse
also cool dass dir aufgefallen ist
die farbe sieht aus wie kann eine farbe
billig aussehen
ich weiß nicht ob du dir den sweater
gekauft hast aber was mir sehr sehr sehr
sehr am herzen liegt sind quasi die
bedingungen wie das hergestellt wird und
auch die qualität also aber wenn man
eine farbe als billig beurteilt okay
drei von fünf punkten
was hätte ich
machen sollen also sie hat gesagt ihr
gefällt das mit dem daumenkino aber was
sie nicht so gut findet ist dass die
farbe billig aussieht
und deswegen gibt sie mir nur drei von
fünf punkten die hanna ist jetzt
natürlich kein renommiertes
bewertungsverfahren die für shops und
keine ahnung was aber ich versuche halt
schon irgendwie es allen irgendwie
rechts machen das alle irgendwie schon
deswegen ziemlich traurig ist die farbe
billig rüberkommt und ich deswegen zwei
abzugs punkte kriege cool ist das da
hallo mein name ist also alle luca kommt
der fans wenn ihr wisst ob das eine
besondere bedeutung hat dann lass es
mich bitte wissen
informiert überhaupt nichts gegen dich
persönlich hanna ich habe dich noch nie
getroffen oder irgendwas also ich will
dich hier mit überhaupt nicht angehen
oder irgendwie beleidigen oder keine
ahnung was aber wenn man doch ein video
über eine person macht und über die
klamotten einer person und sich sogar
die sachen bestellt dann informiert man
sich doch auch ein bisschen und wenn du
dann mal auf einem kanal wärs siehst du
oben steht hallo mein name ist luca und
wenn man auf meinem kanal das erste mal
ist spielt sich sogar automatisch ein
video habe mein name ist luca und ich
sage immer hallo mein name ist luca um
direkt die leute zu begrüßen um zu sagen
wer ich bin wie ich heiße bla bla bla
und deswegen habe ich auf den sweater
schreiben lassen hallo mein name ist
wenn nicht locker hin geschrieben wäre
hätte es nicht ganz gepasst weil nicht
jeder luca heißt deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht so ein paar sonderzeichen
einfach dahin zu machen so von wegen
zensiert das lustige ist ich hatte erst
darum gekämpft dass wir es irgendwie so
hinkriegen dass man beim bestellvorgang
seinen eigenen namen eingeben kann und
damit kommt man quasi seinen eigenen
namen da eingestickt in schwarz auf den
gelben rudi das war allerdings nicht
möglich weil wir einander tausende leute
bestellen dann müsse das immer neu
gemacht werden können auch leute
hinschreiben hallo mein name ist penis
oder irgendwie so und dass man total
bescheuert deswegen hab ich halt einfach
so sonderzeichen gepackt also das zur
erklärung warum der hallo mein name ist
blabla steht es geschrieben und dann ist
sie voll der innenteil der rest ist nur
meine begrüßung die ich seit vier jahren
habt ansonsten ist er ist 30 bequem da
hat es futter was die eigentlich
meistens haben die police von ihm extra
small also xs bis mir trotzdem bis jetzt
soll ja dass das soll halt alles so ein
bisschen wasser ist sein das war halt
die winterkollektion übrigens ganz
lustig sehr das video vor einer woche
hochgeladen am 19 04 und sie bewertet
man eine neue kollektion
ja dies viereinhalb monate alt dort sind
es im schnitt nicht so meins das ist so
cool aber es gibt ein hauptpunkt des
reifens in punkten
warum ich wollte das geld habe ich
wollte es knall ich haben und gelb und
schwarz finde ich ist eine mega geile
fahrt kommen bezüglich des stücks ist
einfach meine begrüßung das ist ein
insider von einer community
beziehungsweise nicht mehr insider
sondern das weiß eigentlich jeder dass
ich immer sage hallo mein name ist utah
und der schnitt das wasser ist dafür
steht die ganze kollektion sogar auf der
website steht ein lästiger gelber
sweater und passform und größe oversize
passform lukas lieblings
sorry aber wenn du dir einen aufs eis
wetter bestellt und dann bemängelt dass
er auf was teils ist dann hast du es
nicht ganz verstanden ich habe mir den
kopf warum macht es einfach ein land in
not ist oder ins minus auf den boden der
tasse und
gar nicht mal so eine tolle idee
eigentlich ich dachte erste was ich soll
jetzt mein gesicht irgendwie auf eine
tasse machen aber dann meinte sie
also den smiley dankeschön dafür die
werbung
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich hab den gelben
sweater viel viel mehr gefeiert als den
dunkelblauen wenn ich frage dann heißt
es meistens ich finds gut wovon die
hälfte super das ist genau mein stil
ich mag es sehr lang ist
das ist der gleiche schnitt wie beim
gelten der blauen loops wetter hat exakt
den gleichen august schnitt wieder gelbe
und dann gelben hast du mir nur zwei von
fünf gegeben wegen der mission entsteht
nicht hey da kannst du mir das
vielleicht mal irgendwann geklärt nach
der schriftzug das heißt es mich andere
kind was wenn das macht ist es ja das
war halt so das ding einerseits wollte
ich halt dass irgendwas fettes drauf
kommt aber andererseits sollte das nicht
so in die fresse merchandise mäßig sein
danke man ja doch der schock ist mir ein
bisschen zu kriegen muss den halt deine
fresse schon 4 gegen 4 45 uhr gestalten
könnten eine meinung hat dieses video zu
den unterschiedlichen teilen nicht sein
aber das ist wahrscheinlich
das
nicht teil der kollektion vom ersten
zwölfter gewesen also ich verstehe
wirklich nicht wie sie das ganze video
jetzt irgendwie aufgebaut hat oder wie
sie sich informiert hat oder so aber mal
schauen wie sie das jetzt bewertet also
für mich sieht es aus als würde man
irgendwie auf wacken gehen aufbacken
a
wir hatten hier vorne dann diesen 3d
print drauf also das war so ein bisschen
das war mit mir ausgeschnitten das war
unten länger geschnitten dass wir unten
dran sich also da bin ich ganz auf
deiner seite das gefällt nicht jedem
changes nicht kaufen würde ich mir das
kann auch nicht ich will es auch nicht
anprobieren einfach mal komplett
auseinandernehmen dieses produkt dafür 1
1 einen punkt danke
minsk the world immer noch null punkte
gehen ohio was ich interessant finde ist
dass sie bisher keiner gesagt haben dass
es eine subjektive einschätzung von
denen ist weil die stellen sie jetzt
gerade da sie ja dass die farbe ist
ledig das heißt die farbe ist auch
billig aber das so wissen wie ich meine
es ist ja quasi nur deren meinung
deswegen ist es für mich halt voll in
ordnung wenn ihr einfach sagt yao das
gefällt uns einfach nicht da gebe ich
jetzt in die null punkte für dieses ding
das heißt allerdings nicht dass es
anderen leuten nicht gefällt und
deswegen es ist eine subjektive
einschätzung der kollektion bereich
kette in wien rock anziehen
stimmt suchen jetzt aber so umhört ödes
soll halt so hüpfen so versteht jeder
dann eigentlich mag ich möchte niemanden
hier niemandes geschmack hier beleidigen
aber noch nicht meins ich habe danke
dass du das gesagt hast also wirklich
jeder hat ja irgendwie eigenen geschmack
es gibt leute die haben gesagt ja ich
fand alle sachen von ihm aber den 2
den kann man ja echt tragen weil es dann
einfach zu dem style von den leuten
gepasst hat also es gibt die meinung es
gibt die meinungen und wenn ihr her den
loser-pool schadet ist es natürlich cool
und wenn ihr den blues hat er nicht viel
verändert ist natürlich auch okay aber
hey man schauen ob sie auch noch etwas
reagiert sie muss einen teufel
jetzt macht mal halblang mal aufgefallen
dass du kein produkten und es wird immer
weniger
das kann ich auch ich dachte sagt das
ist ein 3d druck ist das einzig positive
das einzig positive die nicht möchten
wir von dir ein paar sachen danke würde
ich auch sagen schön gedanken zum pulli
12 points das haben wir 24 prozent
gesagt diese werbung nicht so gut zur
geltung
wieso kommt er da nicht gut zur geltung
schöner wenn eine andere fahrerin
hintergrund wer freilich hast du dir
meinen shop mal angeschaut in meinem
shop ist alles weiß und alles so clean
wie möglich sein
deswegen habe ich auch keine großen
spielen ziehen keine großen web-sites
sachen und verlinkungen und keine ahnung
was ich denke ich einfach alles weiß
haben und das behalte ich natürlich bei
nur damit ein pulli besser zu geld und
kommt werde ich bestimmt nicht
vereinbart auf den hintergrund zu
schwarz ändern da verstehe ich einen 86
punkte
ihr körper kann das bestätigen ich finde
ihn richtig tollen die wenig haben auch
im alltag wenn das hier nicht den usa
hätte dort nicht immer die herzen voll
gegen lucio sorry aber wenn das da nicht
drauf stehen würde dann wäre es ein ganz
normaler rudi sogar mehr sind nicht
irgendwie von mir gebrandet oder so ja
keine ahnung also der pulli wieder muss
ich würde sagen hat sich am allerbesten
bisher verkauft neben dem schwarzen
smiley polyphon 2015 also danke danke
danke freunde der multikulti ist echt
mega kreis bayreuth angekommen
ich weiß nicht ob diese erwähnt hat aber
ihr dürftet ihr auch bestimmen welche
farbkombination das werden sollte und so
weiter und so fort teilweise blieb und
bringen auch mal sowas ohne dass hier
raus an der stelle wird das heutige
wieder ist allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren ich hätte gar nicht
gedacht dass ich jetzt so lange darauf
reagieren weil das video wirklich nur
sechs minuten geht aber natürlich will
ich auch meine eigenen gedanken dazu zu
sagen weil ich ja noch nie so richtig
meine sachen gesprochen habe die ich im
kopf habe und was meine hintergründe der
waren bereits zu beginn gesagt wollte
ich euch auch heute ein neues produkt
vorstellen was am ersten 69 den shop
komplett und zwar dass hier seht ihr das
schlüsselanhänger muss ich glaube ich
nicht viel zu sagen einmal in schwarz
mit seinem dingen hinten steht ganz
klein noch lupen drauf ich weiß ich hab
nichts erkennen kann und einmal in
weißen habe ich schon seit monaten an
meinem schlüssellänge hat man vielleicht
ab und zu mal gesehen und blogs oder so
kommen am ersten sechs in den shop also
das ist das neue produkt was es so noch
nie gab das gibt es ja jedes mal bei mir
jedes halbe jahr kommt ein neuer lounge
am ersten sechs und am ersten zwölf wenn
man das kommt immer ein produkt was es
bisher so noch nicht in meinem shop gab
nüssel anhänger meine damen und herren
jetzt kennt ihr schon viele produkte und
zwar dieses t shirt wie gesagt mit lcd
vorne drauf und sprint hin
der song body kommt dran die jeansjacke
kommt rein die teile hier ja und ich
freue mich wenn ihr am ersten sechsten
mal im shop vorbeischaut gelaunt schon
um 15 uhr
und ja wenn euch das video gefallen hat
last leichter und sonst würde ich jetzt
einfach nur noch sagen
[Musik]